[Music]
the treble Moby's they belong
[Applause]
102 100 acres that's what I do
I mean is it a surprise that I did that
makes it Lakers by one
-
[Applause]
Colby now isolated on Jarrett Jack for
the lead do you want taking one of your
last shots steal him because he feels
like every shot he shoot is going and
that one definitely down the pipe Dixon
in the file back out Brian
shot clock at seven
leaves falling away cuts ahead and the
Lakers take a one-point lead with seven
point three remaining for a clutch shot
once again from Kobe Bryant
[Music]
divided solid rock behind Toby
he is hard to believe
no ignite
laziness came
there anybody more clutch than that
most players talk about warning the last
there's the difference between hot
and making it happen gradually the
Lakers poured away
going up on the belt all the way
[Applause]
now
over time 107 106 to the best in the
game the best closer finisher brings the
hearts of those of the ratleys Center
tonight
with half a minute to play bright
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
g-gary be foolish
respects it too
[Applause]
pain to inbound
three Brian was able to get that ball
cleanly the old Ratliff comes running
out it's a good job
and the Lakers have won the Pacific
Division title our chest lifting gets
you the bridezilla has to put her on the
buzzer
Chicopee
and quit early gotten off the time
Enda three and electors survived to win
their 8th to the row what a
disappointing loss to the man he who so
well here in the fourth quarter
welcome to chip it right with the sale
why you gotta get shot here no seconds
by it's for the win
[Applause]
as Kobe Bryant
the buzzer in overtime gets the win for
Los Angeles
what up at you boy Adam left coach you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report